[Music]
uber is trying to move past recent
scandals and the resignation of CEO
Travis kalanick by changing its
corporate culture those scandals as you
know include sexual assault allegations
and safety issues the ride-hailing giant
hired Bo's amaz st. John remember that
name as its chief brand officer last
month to help turn around the sixty
eight billion dollar company's image we
sat down with her at the press lounge in
New York City the other day to find out
why she is fearless in her new job
you're coming at a really dicey time
where the brand is certainly under fire
there are charges of a company of sexual
harassment drivers behaving badly
customers safety is a concern so you
knew all of that going in yet you still
said I want that job which I think says
something about you probably probably
I'm not afraid I'm not afraid I've never
been afraid of anything and I see
potential that's the opportunity there's
certainly things that have happened that
I don't condone that I'm not comfortable
with I'm not okay with letting
representation matters to as chief brand
officer Beau's a must st. John says
she'll focus on rebuilding ubers
relationship with riders and its drivers
it is a daunting task the company has
recently fired 20 employees after more
than 200 investigation into claims of
sexual harassment and other misconduct
last month its CEO Travis kalanick
resigned well I'm not naive about that
at all and by the way those things are
very serious again it's about trying to
be the representation for what I want to
see you know I want change I want things
to be great for people of color and for
women for us to be able to show up at
work do our best work and be appreciated
for that work so if I can contribute to
that and it's not gonna be easy there's
gonna be lots of challenges you know I'm
sure they'll be frustrating days I'm
sure there'll be times I cry because I
don't mind crying by the way but I'm
hopeful you know and I think that's
really what's driving me is that I'm
hopeful I can see the larger picture was
Travis leaving the company difficult yes
yes I think it's difficult anytime there
is real significant change in a culture
you know that are good so you have to
recalibrate people have to find new
direction new ways of moving new ways of
working so it's always difficult what's
the process now for finding new
leadership at the company well I'm
leaving that to the board okay and those
who are you know empowered to make those
decisions mmm but I hope it's the right
one when you think of Silicon Valley you
don't think of women and you certainly
don't think of diversity you've checked
two boxes yeah we're checking all the
boxes yeah it's true it's true but it
also feels like another opportunity you
know where it feels like the immigration
story you know in Colorado Springs
Colorado my family moved there we were
the first Ghanian family in kado Springs
but by the time I went to college there
were four or five families who were
there I feel the same way now I've
already seen it happen so if I'm there
people can see me maybe you'll come
along too you know there's a call to
action mm-hmm mm-hmm I'm right here your
family moves to Colorado and you said
you felt like an outsider I'm thinking
why do you feel like an outsider you're
tall you're black and you're a woman
yeah what do you mean you didn't fit in
in Colorado and you're from Ghana right
exactly yeah and I was 12 at the time
you know at the time when you don't want
to be different from anyone you don't
want to speak differently certainly
don't wanna have an accent so how do you
take that and make that work for you at
12 for me I turned it into a opportunity
to get to know the people around me
studying pop culture studying and I
didn't know that's what it was called of
course yeah you know but watching TV
shows watching movies listening to the
radio so that at school I could talk
about what other kids were talking about
you know maybe I wouldn't seem so
strange if I connected with them on the
level that they were used to but you
know that seems to have carried out to
your adulthood today yes
st. John's ability to connect helped her
conquer the world of marketing where she
became a powerhouse executive for some
of the world's biggest brands like Pepsi
yeah
and a please I've heard you describe
yourself as a change agent an agent of
change what does that mean
well every every situation is unique you
know in this one part of it is an
evolution you know not such a hard
change so it means talking to people
understanding the motivations talking to
people who are also communicating with
the external team members drivers riders
etc and really trying to combine those
things into a cohesive message at what
felt like the height of st. John's
career she lost her husband Peter to
Burkitt's lymphoma a rare form of cancer
in 2013 people get up and they think
it's going to be a normal day and by the
end of the day your life has changed
your referent
and you have to figure out a way to put
one foot in front of the other and keep
going how did you do that
Wow there I mean a couple of reasons one
he told me - she told you - he told me -
what do you say he told me to keep going
keep hustling mm-hmm
keep hustling keep hustling oh yeah yeah
keep going cuz keep hustling me oh man
it means to do what sometimes is
impossible to do finding the way out of
no way you know keep hustling find the
answers when it doesn't look like there
is an answer I read that you call
yourself super exec you mom yes I do
super exec you mommy yeah because you
know I do have a cape it's hidden yeah
and my collar yeah but you know I'm in
the executive I'm a mom I do everything
to the best of my ability so I feel like
that super what are you teaching your
daughter at this stage in her life
yeah hmm well I hope that she's learning
that lots and lots of things are
possible you know but it's not always
the straight path you know and that just
because something doesn't go right
doesn't mean you go and hide you know
that you get up and try something else
or maybe you try it again try something
again it doesn't work okay new plan
I also like your work philosophy this is
something that was fascinating to me
about when it comes to salary
negotiating tip Oh
tell me because I think this will be
very helpful for a lot of people your
salary negotiating tip is what give the
number first give the number first yes
give the number first and you say make
it high as hell yes make it high as hell
because then you can't be low bald but
that goes against everything we've been
taught everything we've been taught is
let them say it first because you don't
want to throw a number out there first
because maybe you'll price yourself out
of a position well that's part of also
knowing the range you know so do the
work
I mean don't just you know call a number
out of the sky but ya know know the
range and then exceed the range you know
because then you can negotiate down just
a little bit but if you you know allow
someone to give you the number and it's
too low there's no way you can go back
up you can't get that much higher so
you're negotiating from what a start
point what will be your definition of
success for that job for you wow that's
a great question
success will be when I can stand at a
cocktail party and someone will say wow
that's such a cool place to be cuz right
now we're not hearing that about uber
you know you talk about people deleting
their uber apps or going from uber to
lifts you go okay just watch is that
what you're sitting on absolutely
hashtag watch me work dad watches me
worry woman oh she's savvy listen she's
a real firecracker and very confident
she says one of the main things she
wants to do is start telling a new
narrative about uber she said there are
a lot of positive stories there the
people work they're hard-working the
drivers and to let you know exactly who
this company really is she knows it has
a big black eye right now but she's
convinced and when you ask her what's
her theme song of her life diamonds on
the sole of my shoes at Paul Simon song
oh no I thought that was a was a nice
choice for her very interesting yeah I'm
gonna have more about her that's I
haven't seen her do I've seen her in the
papers I haven't seen her do anything or
hers TV interview yeah I'm sure there's
more to come for that bozo ma st. John
you can hear an extended version she's a
single mom or she lost her husband to
cancer years ago she's had a lot of
challenges in her life she's ready so
you can hear more of the interview on
CBS this morning podcast it's available
on iTunes and Apple's podcast app
jeonse explains her technique for salary
negotiations I love this mmm and
adapting to life in Colorado as a
teenage immigrant from Ghana